[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 19 avril
un plan local d'urbanisme pour imaginer
coignières en 2030 la ville organisé une
réunion d'information au théâtre
alphonse daudet pour évoquer les
principales orientations du futur paix
est lui un document qui fixera d'ici à
quelques mois les règles en matière
d'urbanisme pour les 15 prochaines
années la france insoumise de jean-luc
mélenchon à maurepas un rassemblement
des militants locaux se tenait en salle
du conseil municipal avec comme
thématique principale les quartiers
populaires des quartiers qui pourrait
faire basculer le scrutin dans quatre
jours et puis du sport dans l'actualité
locale le sky rugby organisée il ya
quelques jours une compétition avec des
équipes venus de sept pays européens
une compétition pour les 8 13 ans
remporter ironie du sort par les jeunes
anglais quel visage pour coignières dans
quinze ans c'est à cette question que
doit répondre le plan local d'urbanisme
une nouveauté pour la commune qui a
intégré l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'an passé une nouvelle réunion
d'information était organisée sur ce
sujet hier soir au théâtre
alphonse daudet le maire et son équipe
municipale ont présenté les grandes
orientations de ce document entre
préservation du cadre de vie et
nouvelles constructions reportage à quoi
ressemblera coigné en 2030 comment
rendre complémentaires le volet rural et
commercial de la ville
près d'une centaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour cette réunion publique et
écouter le maire a exposé ses
propositions pour l'aménagement et le
développement durable de la commune est
d'ici 15 ans coignières un peu plus de
4300 habitants devrait voir sa
population augmenter de 28%
nous devons aussi construire des
logements sur coignières
c'est une nécessité pour que coignières
vivent également nous avons des secteurs
commerciaux intéressant nous avons un
secteur industriel également intéressant
mais il nous faut également construire
des logements parce qu'il nous faut
accueillir les personnes qui ont un
parcours résidentiel et qui veulent
rester sur panière pour préserver son
image de village à la campagne la
majorité a détaillé aux habitants quatre
grandes orientations et une vingtaine de
points parmi ceux ci la diversification
de l'offre de logement le renforcement
de l'attractivité commerciale ou encore
comme attrape récemment l'enfouissement
de la nationale 10 ce qui est important
entre autres c'est sur ce préalable de
la nationale 10 cette histoire
d'enfouissement qui était dans les
cartons mais dont on pense pas que ce
serait quand même quelque chose qui soit
acté quoi comme ça moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose
une bonne démarche surtout des questions
sur le
l'augmentation du nombre de logements du
fait que manière est resté intraitable
depuis 40 ans et donc aussi sur le
l'accessibilité qui était intéressante
aussi une nouvelle réunion publique est
prévue le 5 juillet prochain
l'approbation du pmu est prévu quand
elle pour juin 2010 8 à elancourt le
handicap est au coeur d'une semaine
spéciale jusqu'au 22 avril la ville
souhaite à travers cette semaine changer
le regard que portent ses habitants sur
le handicap grâce à divers animations
est encore l'un d'eux s'étant avait lieu
cet après midi avec un atelier de
pâtisserie adapté à l'agora patrick
jacques de dixmude et mélanie poker ont
vite eu peu d'effets ans nordine se
lance dans la préparation d'un mendiant
une pâtisserie au chocolat ils
participent à un atelier culinaire pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
ouais vraiment parce que j'aime bien
dans le
patrice faye c'est la grève la cousine
la pâtisserie du monde au nez des
chocolats j'ai lu j'élis fondu dans le
micro-ondes et après comme je dis sortie
de limoux monde
j'ai les raser qu'il se soit bien vendu
et après il me donnait 1 m de recettes
le plastique est mon mini trous et après
j'ai commencé
à mettre dans les ports les papiers une
recette simple des explications courte
l'animation est faite par l'association
élan courtoise la toque au coeur je suis
concernée par le handicapeur armes à ma
fille en fait était en fauteuil roulant
et donc c'est une activité qu'on
pratique souvent à la maison donc doux
d'où l'idée en fait de créer une
association pour ce à partir avec sa
création et puis c'est vrai que je crée
aussi une petite fiche recette donc qui
vont qui leur permet de pouvoir refaire
à la maison avec les petites techniques
que j'ai donné pendant cours douze
apprentis pâtissiers se sont essayés à
la cuisine du chocolat depuis mardi à
elancourt c'est la semaine du handicap
d'autres animations sont prévues jusqu'à
samedi politique à présent et les
soutiens yvelinois de jean luc mélenchon
qui a organisé il ya quelques jours une
réunion publique en salle du conseil
municipal à maurepas en présence
notamment des membres de l'équipe du
candidat de la france insoumise ils se
sont vus exposé les propositions de
leurs favoris pour les quartiers
populaires alors que c'est peut-être
dans ces quartiers que ce jour à l'accès
au second tour ils étaient environ 80 ce
soir-là écouté attentivement les
solutions exposées dans le programme de
jean luc mélenchon pour les quartiers
populaires lutte contre le chômage santé
transports ou encore logement les
propositions sont nombreuses
en préambule la france insoumis souhaite
changer le regard sur ces quartiers
qu'elle estime oubliés des politiques
publiques
tant qu'on considérera que les quartiers
populaires sont un problème on cherchera
à éviter de regarder ce qui s'y passe
or les quartiers populaires c'est avant
tout une grande richesse une richesse
démographique une richesse culturelle
artistique une richesse sportive
économique et même une refaire une
richesse civique puisqu'aujourd'hui la
lutte contre les discriminations elle
s'exerce essentiellement à partir des
quartiers populaires priorité absolue de
jean-luc mélenchon pour les quartiers
les plus fragiles l'éducation l'ancien
sénateur socialiste veut notamment
réduire les effectifs par classe 25
élèves maximum au lycée il souhaite
aussi recruté 60000 enseignants ou
encore développer massivement
l'enseignement professionnel et
technologie
après quand y'a de l'éducation et quand
il ya une perspective d'une autre vie
qu'une vie essentiellement basée sur le
commerce et sur l'accumulation de biens
dans les banlieues et bonne raison qu'on
se sente plus mal qu'ailleurs dans son
équipe il ya quand même des gens qui
sont qui sont issus de
différents quartiers différents courants
et qui peuvent représenter des choses
qui peuvent répondre à des attentes que
peuvent avoir les gens dans les
quartiers populaires est d'après les
derniers sondages jean luc mélenchon
semble pouvoir accéder au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
une des clés de son score se trouve
probablement dans le vote des classes
populaires
un vote qui depuis quelques années se
tournent de plus en plus vers marine le
pen
nous vous en parlions mardi soir le
week-end dernier était organisé à
trappes le mondial d'improvisation
d'improvisation excusez-moi juniors
quatre équipes participer à l'événement
la france la belgique la suisse et le
canada et pour cette troisième édition
ce sont les jeunes français qui se sont
imposés en finale face au québécois de
justesse 7 à 6 retour sur cette victoire
avec ce sujet de mélanie poquet
[Musique]
ils inscrivent leur nom au palmarès
victoire de justesse pour les français
en face les québécois n'ont rien lâché
la france l'emportent cette a6 sera
salée grand tout c'est pour toi la
falaise de la terreur on lorsqu'on
l'avait corps a pas tellement
d'importance ce qui compte
alors ce qui compte je pense c'est
surtout s'amuser on peut dire qu'on a
réussi un mondial un match quand on
s'est amusé je pense que il n'ya pas de
gens qui peuvent dire qu'ils ont réussi
blanc match on s'étend pas amusé après
quatre jours de compétition l'équipe de
france vient de remporter le 3e mondial
d'improvisation juniors face à elle le
québec la belgique et la suisse de jouer
à l'étranger effectivement ta chance
tout simplement parce qu'on se rencontre
avec d'autres équipes qui finalement
même si on a une même langue il ya des
styles de jeu qui sont différents et
c'est surtout ça qui est intéressant se
trouve dans un tournoi à l'étranger
c'est de se confronter pas seulement à
une improvisation anthem à des
personnages mais à une autre manière de
jouer de parler même parfois dix membres
dont certains n'ont pas le droit
[Rires]
après l'assassinât des 7 à la france dé
recevoir derrière la logistique l'équipe
ii dès qu'ils perdent ce fut super bien
passé franchement c'était trop cool il
ya eu de grands moments de fête des
grands moments de de plaisir de partage
de de fun du jeu il ya eu de l'impro
enfin je sais pas comment je peux le
définir mais si je dois essayer de
résumer ce qui s'est passé ça a été
vraiment un vrai carrefour de la culture
de l'improvisation théâtrale en fête et
du match d'improvisation parce que
chacun est venu avec un petit peu ses
manières de faire et où ils sont adaptés
à ce qu'on nous propose à trappes
prochaine édition la quatrième ce sera
au québec un tournoi itinérant cette
fois dans le reste de l'actualité locale
une première à guyancourt le centre
social du conte du rotois organisé ce
week end un tournoi de jeux d'échecs
depuis la rentrée est des cours sont
proposés aux enfants du cp à la 3e dans
le cadre du soutien scolaire donnée par
le centre est djamel breillat et le
responsable du centre social
écoutez le l'idée en fait de développer
le premier tournoi de jeux d'échecs
résultent surtout dans notre volonté en
fait de créer un événement
intergénérationnel
on sait que cette pratique là peut
s'adresser à tous les publics
on connaît toutes ses vertus à savoir un
travail sur la concentration l'activité
élabora trice l'autonomie l'organisation
également la confiance en soi
et puis aussi la volonté de la volonté
de vaincre de réussir on referme ce
journal avec un chiffre 750 soit le
nombre de jeunes venus de toute l'europe
pour participer à la nouvelle édition du
tournoi de rugby européen lucien palace
organisé par le ska et rugby l'événement
était réservé à des jeunes de 8 à 13 ans
avec notamment une équipe venue de
sibérie
au total deux jours de matches et des
rencontres dans la bonne humeur et une
victoire britannique au final alors
l'anguille et yves hub stand berger
voici l'équipe belge
ici l'équipe italienne est là les russes
de jeunes rugbymen de sept pays
européens se sont affrontées le week end
dernier sur la pelouse d'elancourt et
dans ce genre de tournois gagnés à peu
d'importance c'est la rencontre des
cultures qui compte c'est différent
parce qu'il ya des hommes nouveaux clubs
tu connais pas leur style de jeu et a
aussi des nouvelles règles donc c'est
très intéressant et on découvre en cas
de choses qu'on connaît pas la boire
belgique et c'est super chouette
et attention ne pas confondre les règles
d'un pays à un autre dans les mêlées en
belgique on peut pas bouger
on veut pas quand j'ai testé la balle
quand n'est qu'en france on pousse on
comptait sur la balle ça change pour les
entraîneurs le voyage prend aussi la
forme d'un défi normands n'ont joue en
italie mais elles vont très bien
organisé et les niveaux de niveau
sportif les niveaux de compétition
seront très haut pour les organisateurs
cette édition qui a réuni sept pays
européens est une réussite
les années précédentes le club n'avait
pas attiré autant d'équipés étrangères
on en rit notw à l'international à
différents tournois juste français qui
se conduit régulièrement et sont sympas
pour faire vivre au chd des choses
différentes aux jeunes en fait c'est
vraiment ça l'idée c'est de jouer avec
des adversaires qui parlent pas la même
langue que nous eh ben c'est ça plus
rien à voir c'est l'équipe d'oxford qui
a remporté le tournoi mais tous les
jeunes apprentis rugbymen sont repartis
vers leur pays
l'esprit plein de beaux souvenirs c'est
la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci de
nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]